and this is the British Muslim Heritage
Center in Manchester that we're about to
visit
[Music]
guys we're here what's called the House
of Wisdom you often hear the common
ignorant statements of people who just
don't know that's why we have a big job
ahead of us to help educate the people
and it's it's a shame that people are
such foolishness that
what did Muslims contribute to the world
and I'm at the House of Wisdom and I
really encourage our brothers and
sisters of humanity to visit one of
these or do your research and we have
are going to go through some of the
things that Muslims who are living Islam
how it's not encouraged all of these
thinking and pondering and reflecting
and LED them to form what we're gonna
see here in the House of Wisdom let's
take a look alright let's go through the
this is the welcome to the House of
Wisdom exhibition at the Muslim heritage
centers we're starting here with
cleanliness talk to us about this why is
this important highlights the
contribution of Muslim Muslim
civilization in in the areas of science
medicine and things that have
contributed to a civilization around the
world so for this one it was actually
Allah Rossi who came up with the first
recipe for soap and then all first
recipe for soap from this Muslim eldrazi
this is how important cleanliness is in
Islam I heard back then people weren't
even taking baths yeah I heard the
French they came up with the perfume to
put over a person who wasn't even taking
a bath that amassed stench is this
correct this a French man was telling me
this been on here now we're going even
to perfume
okay perfume is something which is very
important in Islam it was one of the
things know by Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam so this is
just to highlight the importance of
perfume
all right that's after you clean
yourself you wash yourself that's how
important is we cover that let's keep on
moving to okar pitch you got carpets up
here why do you have carpets of your
quality of design by the Muslims in the
car
it's was so popular that even royalty in
Europe they wanted to have carpets made
by Muslims for example Queen Eleanor she
wanted one another's here we have some
of the artifacts that we have and the
rarest artifacts in the exhibition is
here we have a key of the Kaaba from
1910 and also we have some coins the
coin in the middle is actually from 95
eh 95 after Hijri that's literally a key
from the Kaaba from 1910 how do they
verify that that's for sure this was
from a private collector
yeah because was back in the day the
cloth of the Kaaba and the key of the
Kaaba used to be made in Egypt and
supported through the middle-eastern 85
years after the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu son passed away was minted
yeah so this is from the time of the
Umayyad caliphate so moving on giving
you guys a quick tour of the house of
wisdom from 1818 okay moving along here
so we have now architecture again so
many buildings in Europe which iconic
buildings actually took much of the
style of the building from Islamic
architecture and you'll have all this
here a brief history explained all right
yes okay moving along then you have a
graffiti we have calligraphy many people
know about that yes it's more Oh coffee
if you're a coffee lover and I'm sure
most of you are what does that have to
do with Islam so the word coffee is
actually derived from the Italian term
cafe which itself is derived from the
Turkish word cafe which comes from the
Arabic word Kawa okay
so are you saying are we saying that
look did Muslims event coffee yeah
exactly an Arab goat named Khalid who
came he what he discovered was that his
goats they became lively after they ate
a particular red berry yeah so then he
then took those those berries took the
seeds boiled it and then came up with
coffee
Wow so next time you are gonna bash
Muslims in Islam think about the coffee
you're drinking there and have a second
thought to look more into it get
educated let's go on and schools what is
this so a schooling first appeared in
the masajid as early as the 7th century
so this explains and highlights that how
it been for I started from the Mossad
genes and then came up to the
universities the first university in the
world was actually started by a Muslim
lady called Fatima a theory in Morocco
yeah this is known Fatima lv3 so many
for many people who say that Islam
subjugates warming keeps them uneducated
the first university in the world was
started by a Muslim woman how many
people knew that and you guys going
through this you can go ahead and pause
but if you're watching it on and read to
the rush that we're bringing you so many
famous philosophers writers travel to
the Middle East to study from Islamic at
Islamic universities this is this coin
this panel here is the most interesting
one
for me personally the golden coin the
golden coin the King of England in 785
his name was king offer he was the king
of mercy and England we're going about
1200 years now 1300 years he had gold
coins minted with the testimony of the
Shahada inscribed onto the coins why did
he have the Shahada on there so there's
a difference of opinion why there's
about two three different theories of
why he did that
the original coins are in the British
Museum so as you can see offer that's
his name and that's with the the Kalima
on day Wow on the reverse of the coin is
Oh
do some say he accepted Islam possibly
blessing one fede that's one theory and
hinges come out okay algebra algebra
what do you have to say about that and I
mean now if you can if people point to
the modern-day gadgets that they have
that we wouldn't have them yeah
iPhone compute all of this stuff because
the algorithms right all of the codes
come from what the Muslims invented yes
is that right algebra so again before
you start bashing Islam look at the
contributions that it made motivating
Muslims to come up and invent these are
all Muslim adventures yes al Kindi he
was one of the pioneers in cryptography
and you know be from that people use
that for codes during in in wars and
cryptic codes and so on astronomy
he was the first Muslim to construct
Astro lobes it was alpha sorry
are these things where people can
obviously verify go check up and do
research the other what a website yes
the website these are the stuff that you
can actually look up and research into
more detail yeah you know we're just one
of these panels it can be an exhibition
by itself medicine and treatment this is
when you had real healing medicine we're
not talking about today we're we're just
masking the symptoms these were actually
healers
really healing for example including
Xena he wrote a text which was used
across Europe on the Islamic world and
many of the doctors and surgeons used to
travel to the Muslim world to study with
the Muslim here's a big one Hospital yes
yes so in the time of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu Salaam this you
could see the first hospital service was
established in the courtyard of the
prophet's mosque in Medina uh-huh and
then the first organized hospital in the
world was the Atman in Toulon hospital
in Cairo from 87 to Wow you have all
these contributions that Islam made why
don't most of the world know about it
yes windows I didn't know about this one
windmills in world yeah kitab he ordered
the first construction of the first
windmill in the Muslim world
it wasn't until five hundred years later
yeah that when some of the Crusades
returned to Europe that they started
building windmills in Europe we got
clocks you guys are just getting a taste
here clocks Islamic civilization
credited look at this telling the time
optics and so the ancient Greeks they
used to have the belief that our how we
see is because our eyes in which race
but it was a banal - a Muslim
mathematician astronomer and physicist
who came up with the idea was actually
due to the light objects that we can see
and he invented the first pinhole camera
as well Wow
paper mills so this is so you can write
on obviously right paper yeah it says
the first paper was not established in
Christian Europe until 1293 and then
what's this one he produced many works
and he made a huge globe on made out of
four hundred kilograms of silver which
recorded the continents the trade routes
the lakes the rivers the major cities
the plains and so on alright guys this
is the house of wisdom can anybody come
and visit so anybody there not yet
Muslims people who are sick of being
lied to
had the will pull over their eyes they
are intelligent they want to get more
informed come to the house of wisdom
here in Manchester at the British Muslim
Heritage Center British Muslim Heritage
Centre in Manchester UK now if somebody
wants to come in and visit what do you
exactly do you guys do here well we have
no food no policy open doors not closed
you hear that open-door policy for
everyone by the Muslim or non-muslim
anyone really and I saw the exhibition
that you have yeah the Muslim
contribution is that to the world yes
absolutely
and not only contribution to the world
but also contribution of Muslims in
first of all and second world war
amazing yes and this is interesting is
that very few people actually know about
it even in Britain who was at the heart
of this whole issue but only 2% of the
people actually know the contribution of
the Muslims so soft and said that you
know what's she doing here why you here
etc what they don't understand is the
freedom you enjoying they also give
their blood before this as well wow
that's deep the freedom that you enjoy
did you hear that mashallah so this is
this is exactly the the whole idea of
this particular project the British most
American Center was after 9/11 there was
a stigma attached the Muslim community
and there was a lot of negativity in the
media negativity amongst non-muslims in
Europe and America and we came there
some people like but Absalon myself and
others came together and when we thought
we need to do something about it
although it might be in a small way but
we need to have a company we have to
contribute toward that problem what's
amazing about the center is that this is
a heritage building it's a great to
store listed building which has got
amazing history to Britain itself as a
Muslim community were part and parcel of
Britain they all sleep oat this preserve
this returned it to its original form
and they are now building this as a
heritage for the Muslims as well and
centre where we can have community
relations strengthened where we can link
up with the different countries as well
so reach out because under the day we
live in a global village we only have
one humanity one world we all have a
responsibility to take step towards one
another the doors open come and visit
Manchester right yes